all right Jenny is with us Jenny's in
Charlotte North Carolina hi Jenny how
are you hi great Dave what manner to
speak with you you too what's up quick
background and then my question for you
I'm a stay-at-home mom to a new baby and
my husband makes about a hundred and
five thousand dollars a year and he is a
CPA
he's the nerd of our family he's a very
cautious vendor and so he diagnoses
himself with a disease called analysis
paralysis so they don't you used before
so so really long time to make a
decision sometimes never making a
decision on a big topic rewind seven
years ago in his previous marriage he
had made some money mistakes
he ended up short selling his home which
were assuming has dinged his credit
pretty badly but fast-forward to now the
last few years we've been really
aggressively saving we have our
emergency fund we have enough of a down
payment to put down about 30% on a
15-year fixed which we're really excited
about and I think I made a really huge
mistake today I received a call from a
collector and it was on behalf of my
little babies physician and I must have
been flustered because they told me I
had an outstanding bill of $25.00 and so
instead of calling my husband asked what
I should do I just paid the debt via my
debit card and when I call my husband to
tell about it he's just upset now and
feeling really defeated that oh cause I
forgot the important part which is we've
also started the baby steps in getting
our first home which is climbing a
realtor that's a high octane realtor and
also we did the very basic preliminary
pre-approval check which wheat for a
loan which we were denied for we're
assuming because of the short sale in
the past but we also think if we did an
in-depth pre-approval check that we
would be approved and so now my husband
is feeling really defeated that needs if
even engaging with this collector
because he thinks the collector lied he
paid that bill about two weeks ago that
this is going to be another
I'd flag for us it is true are we did I
kind of screw things up here is nothing
I can do the fact that you paid it
didn't screw things up you may lost the
$25.00 because it's already been laid
you may not get it back but that's not
the other world but you didn't confirm
it was in collections it was already in
collections and it sounds like the bill
was not that late and it was only $25
and this was your doctor it was the
hospital where I gave birth okay and how
long had it been ago well it was my
daughter was born August 5th so was in a
reunion and it lost in austen Ohio if
you must have gotten it lost in the
shuffle you know I probably I take blame
for that I have a lot of bills that are
lost in the shuffle are you that
disorganize no no no it's like I said my
husband's a CPA he's the one that takes
care of all the finances he does a great
job so could this be just stuff false
could this have even you know it could
have been a lie it couldn't have been
turned over to collections at this early
date they should have just mailed you
the khamar - then you should have gotten
two or three bills in the mail long
before they send into collections I mean
what was once a month since August you
should have gotten a bill how do all
those fall through the cracks
so I mean it's the hospital's fall
because I mean they're the ones that are
being incompetent and then they turn it
over to collections so yeah they cut the
fact that they turn it over to
collections
regardless of how you paid the bill is
what got you it's going to ding you but
that's not that's not because you paid
them over the phone it was already their
way I can can I call the hospital and
kind of run a scenario through or do
they know if you can on it down and get
them to withdraw the fact that they turn
it over to collections maybe before they
report it to the credit bureau has gone
into collections if you can keep them
from reporting it to the credit bureau
and I would chew their butts okay this
is kind of absurd that you turn a a 25
dollar bill over to collections and be
you never let me know or maybe let me
know once or what I mean I never never
saw a single piece of mail from you
people and didn't like I'm moved
you know so I mean do you just is this
how you do your run your business over
there you know so because it's going to
ding your credit if they turn it over to
the collection to the credit bureau as
an accountant on the collections yes
that harms your credit number of
accounts in collections certainly paid
or unpaid unpaid is worse paid is better
so yeah you're probably okay you know
but I'm going to run this to ground and
make sure that the every a bill that's
over there is paid and that these idiots
aren't turning this stuff over to the
credit bureau and because it is going to
affect your ability to move forward on
the house hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]